je suis pas totalement pour qu'on
l'augmente pour toutes les catégories ce
qu'on a fait une première fois c'est une
confirmation dans les prochaines
semaines sur les prix de l'alimentation
je pense qu'il faudra le regarder après
la bataille qu'on mène pour vous parler
franchement c'est plutôt de faire
baisser les prix donc je préférerais de
manière générale qu'on arrive à faire
baisser les prix et qu'on n'est pas
besoin d'augmenter les bourses pour les
étudiants les chevaux 7 et en tout cas
les plus modestes sinon on le fera donc
s'il y a une hausse des prix qui se
poursuit il y aura une augmentation
les plus importants